the Quran tell me thisy and tell them to
come here they they won't I guarantee
you they won't talk to me why not cuz I
know the Quran they won't no they won
wey it want try it
[Music]
come it's
God it's
[Music]
God why this is why I was born like this
some sometimes you don't have to ask why
you do this is this is the faith you
have well so that that's that's true but
a reason for your faith is important
right what is it you you have to be able
to tell this is the beauty of Islam the
faith that you have without even asking
why but you need to is to in the
wrong you it's possible so the people
who grew up Christian they're they're
right that's not what the Quran says
you
have just like free to think you you
think so but but this is about like this
is life and death this is this is your
salvation and my salvation if we go to
heaven or hell depends on where we put
our faith in okay what same God what's
what's the point of TR same God so I'm
Christian yeah so it's not the same same
God I think it's the same God do you do
you believe that Jesus is God yes do you
believe that Jesus is God it's not it
matter it does okay the representation
of
but but see he will he in his book it
says that you're a liar and your book
says he his book is a liar no it's not a
they're not saying that it's a lie it it
does EXC you know you know what you know
chapter 98 ver6 you know what we say
what we say to the Quran there's
something you have your religion I have
my religion okay you know my Prophet
Muhammad he was married to a Christian
woman work yeah it worked the prophet
Muhammad no who was this Christian wife
oh you don't know about as long as you
don't know the story I'm not going to Li
I've never heard that he was married to
a Christian woman who was married to you
not a Christian no no no no Christian
what was her name go look at it I've
never seen that go look at it yeah this
that that's not that's not true if you
say so I don't I don't think he's lying
well I wouldn't say that he's lying I
think he might be a little misinformed
here I wouldn't say he's lying look at
but uh but yeah it's not the same it's
not the same religion or same God you
know same God I just want to know what's
why can't it be I'm Christian I'm
Christian good good so so same here
right so if if you say God is this
person right let's say like for example
let's let's talk about what's your
mother's name d d d d yeah okay so let's
say um I know I also know Doula okay and
doua is a
6ot um
round um young woman you know who's uh
16 years old are we talking about the
same D exactly so how you describe God
your concept of God does not match the
same concept of God in Islam you guys
are talking about two different gods
exactly God has the same properties in
both
religions his question is important what
is the problem yeah what's the problem
so the problem is is that if you have
the wrong God right if you have a false
idea of God then you do not have
salvation you do not have your soul is
going to heaven or hell type of thing so
if you don't have the real Christ the
Bible says if you don't have Christ
you're condemned if you have the true
Christ you'll be saved if you believe in
him and put your faith in so that's why
it's important it's life and death for
us even in
Christianity 100 different variations
ofan that inter
interpret hi
huh nice to meet you too she was called
Maria Maria the cop
Maria mar mar the that that was a Jew
that a Jewish woman right he never
married
anyway According to Islamic tradition
Prophet Muhammad was married to a
Christian woman
named oh okay okay interesting okay
that's so so so what what do you about
all even in Christianity there's 100
different interpretation of of
Christianity but hold on hold on there's
there's there's core values in
Christianity right so even yeah have you
compared Orthodox toath Catholic right
so you have you have the core doctrines
that Catholics and Orthodox agree with
there's differences yes but they no sure
but they agree on the same core
doctrines that make them Christian so
but in Islam you have differences as
well in in Orthodox uh Jesus is the son
of God and in Catholic in Catholic he's
the son of God as well no Jesus Is God
no the Son of God is God the Son of God
is a Divine title for God showing that
he is one in with that Orthodox says
only God is God Jesus is the
son believe in the
Trinity
I they're they're
trinitarians so trinitarians believe
that the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit that's Orthodox catholic whatever
those are that's a core Doctrine
Christianity in Islam they reject the ch
he say God is Not TR you he's only one
person Allah so you have a different God
than the god that's preached in Islam
you guys are not the same and it's
important that you that's your friend
yes so as a Christian who believes in
Christ and whoever is not in Christ is
condemned you as a Christian should tell
him like no I interfere no you need to
your lord tells you why why do I have to
because Jesus said that whoever does not
believe in the son is condemned already
this is your friend
yeah this is the difference like in
Islam they don't say this in Islam ISL
the same no no no no okay no bro I know
what I'm saying okay there is there's
there is a verse in Islam
called look anyways any no listen don't
don't go off I want you to hear this I
don't need to I'm not going to change my
point that's okay it's a conversation
like I'm not trying to change your mind
but this is good to chapter 98:6 in the
Quran thank you chapter 98:6 I'm not
sure if this is right I can I canot I do
you know a of course I do can you can
you get the a come on we we got your
cover
man got I got you man look I'm your
friend here you know this is what we do
which one you want uh give me the house
I don't know give the B house there
there's a few different K so maybe
you'll where you where you where you
from Egypt Egypt okay yeah the house one
is the right not not the not the okay so
you read Arabic also I don't read Arabic
just certain words stud go to chapter
98: 6 show
something you wait because the way by
the way by the way because I know what
you're saying you're right by the way
I'm not saying like that sometimes it's
written that you should sh from them the
Christians and so on as long as the
Christians are saying the same right no
not as long as the Christian saying the
you saying this we're just saying this
no no no look I'm going please just go
to the chap I'm showing you the reason
why I'm pulling this up is because he's
saying that it's not right for us to say
if a person is you know condemned her
going to hell like in Christianity if we
do that he said this is not what we do
in Islam
I'm I'm about to show you a verse in the
Quran that literally does this it says
those who do not believe amongst the
Jews and the Christians and the
polytheists will have their abod in
Hellfire they are the worst of creatures
the Quran says that's the old test no
this is the
Quran tell me where are the closest
toilet you the B
toilet toilet right there behind the
truck you did you get to the verse I get
to the verse
one so what about the one I
was I see see you got because I'm not
going to change my mind anymore yeah
it's not about changing mind bro it's
about about open discussion
bro it's not even like a validate for me
it's it's a valid conversation bro cuz
you could be lost or I could be lost we
just talk yeah you but bro listen listen
you're a Christian this is your friend
okay you as a Christian look can you uh
can we get the bible really quick I just
want to show you one verse and then you
can go
okay yeah yeah we're almost done I'm sh
one verse and then you can go why is
that so hard one verse and you can
go you as a Christian this is your
responsibility which Bible this is King
James King James version whatever Bible
you have at home you can go and get get
the same verse okay
look this is what what Jesus says in
this famous verse famous passage for God
so loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whoever believes in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life okay let's keep going
for he for God did not send his son into
the world to condemn the world but that
the world might be saved through him he
who believes in Him is not condemned but
he who does not believe is condemned
already because he has not believed in
the name of the only begotten son
maybe that's not their fault whe whether
it's their fault or not it's it's
it's it's fault no if you apply
psychology
Environ God has a way of doing this
right let's say he never heard this
before there's a reason why God brought
him here to heal the goel now it is he
he has no there's no excuse what do you
mean by no excuse there's no you you're
hearing the gospel message you're it's
being presented to you he's asking like
you know what if it's not their fault
that they don't believe I'm giving you
the gospel of of the Son of God if you
reject it that's
fine the version of this a bit different
but the same what do you mean I mean
Quran they have lots of similar messages
the Quran you see how it says that God
gave his son the Quran says whoever says
that Jesus is the son of God is perverse
is cursed Allah fights against that
person that's Chapter 9: 30 okay you
don't have the same religion you can't
it's not the same
religion the same God I believe it's the
same how if he rejects
the
Allah so we know okay does Allah have a
son does Allah have a son no we don't we
don't by the the way it's not the same
God you're right Allah doesn't have a
son that means it's not the same God
something that we're going to agree on
because by default you're going to have
your own belief I'm going to have my own
beliefs I just I want you to I want you
to stand on your belief that's fine but
I don't want this confusion saying that
we serve the same God because we don't
and it's important that we know that
this the only that we don't Ser for not
just that but that it's important that
we serve the right God so you need to
know if you're serving a right go the
true God is the triying god father Son
and Holy Spirit Jesus coming down in the
flesh right dying for our sin and
raising up again on the third day to buy
you back this is this is why you yes
I don't believe thean tell this guy and
you tell them to come here they they
won't I guarantee you they won't talk to
me why not cuz I know the Quran they
won't no they won't we try it you want
to try it
come
so so we we know that we serve a
different God right you don't believe
God is trium I
do right so do I but we don't believe
the same thing about the
creat
want no just reason because they they
wanted we were talking to
them I told you I told you he has the
right you're right he has the right I'm
not going
to you have YouTube
he has the R by the way no you're right
like but I but didn't I tell you I said
they're not going to want to talk to I
mean go go to YouTube type one message
Foundation there are like and go on
YouTube and type in God logic
apologetics you see how one message
Foundation runs from to debate and talk
how
you are you sincere to Lear the truth so
are you sincere like if you're sincere
they were asking sincere questions all
of them they're you know they're not
they don't have a dog in Sp you guys are
not sincere you're just here why why why
not how are we not sincere when we just
simply compare our our our our ideas so
you want to learn no no no I want to see
the bring the big guying the big guy
bring your over there the big guy go to
YouTube and see
the see wa y'all take care man it was
look please remember what we talked
about okay I don't interfere in other
people's religions but you should no
because it's h it's
you cannot one day Christian and I don't
like when people try to convince me that
I shouldn't be Christian no you no you
should be Christian and you should want
everyone to be Christian uh no no
because this causes problems exactly the
difference this CA problem no that's if
you're a Muslim and you think that
that's the way to heaven and you don't
try to convince me of that and I'm going
to help I don't believe then you should
tell me if you care about me I can
actually try to tell you exactly the
benefit behind being Muslim but I cannot
force you
of course not but if you think that's
not a question if you think that's the
way to get to God and I don't believe
let say an atheist wouldn't you care
enough about me to share that like I
don't care I like it when my Muslim
friends share that with me I like it
when my Mormon friends share that with
me course so why are you not okay with
with sharing if you think it's important
because personally I don't have the the
the no we can we can discuss but I I I
have am P something but you should be
open cuz that's how we learn the full
picture okay but what I believe is that
by faith and by Common Sense and by the
book I believe in is that um they at
track as well as
you okay but the only point I can like
go against you in it is that we don't
have the same no we do have the same I
agree with this you can't say that you
can't you can't say when you when you
when you when you make a statement like
that bro whether or not you believe it
if we actually examine what we're saying
and we compare and TR we can't say that
we have the same God and it and it
matters it's it's heaven or hell I look
I care no it doesn't this is why you
have the this is why the verse says you
follow your religion and I follow mine
that's what the Quran says because it
knows we don't serve the if the religion
is different then it's a different God
right no it's the same God the same God
trust me it's the same God the same God
je exactly it's the same people Jews yes
it's the same God of
Jewish it's the same God of Muslim it's
it's impossible it doesn't work the same
religion and they don't believe in the
same principles like that Jesus is the
it's not the same ReliOn it's the same
God his God tells some people to kill
other people if they all of the same God
what do you mean like the Hadith where
it says like in the last day that the
Jews will be killed by the Muslims why
would he say to do that if they worship
the same God this is not the point we're
trying to make question no no no he was
trying to make a point you're saying
it's the whether yeah exactly why you
say kill the Jews then I'm I'm telling
you he's the same God I answer the
question that's I'm just saying you
believe in the Trinity he doesn't it's a
different God Jews
don't which wait which Jews Jews the
Jews they don't believe that's not true
there's don't believe Jesus there's
messian have you heard of Messianic Jews
yeah but he's not here yet for no no no
no Messianic Jews Messianic Jews are
Jews who believe that Jesus is the
Messiah the Son of God who came
huh those are the ones are misguided in
falsehood oh but the but the correct the
the Jews are following the correct
religion
there there's a lot of Jews are not a
monolith there's a lot of different you
know so but it's important guys is
you're a Christian too you got a cross
man this is important man you can't look
we cannot as Christians as brothers in
in Christ I'm talking to you as brothers
in Christ okay I my Muslim friend died a
few months ago was very close his name
was Abdul right and we talked about the
gospel all the time and I knew that it
was my I felt even worse when he died
because he died a Muslim and I feel like
I didn't do enough maybe it's not his
fault no no it's it's all it's our fault
we're grown we're mature if you learn
about psychology and all this stuff God
in our opinion we all have same God so
this is all man so
let's this is important man okay this is
important you can't it's about salvation
when someone grows up and his brain is
formed and everything he learns in his
childhood and everything it's very hard
to change something that inside that's
true but that doesn't mean that it's not
his fault yeah know
is oh my God
logic